as Sacramento at your listening station
you hear zero one zero and you said I
can't be right
what's the simplest thing to do to try
and find out what the weather really is
because you know the known errors
occurred we've talked about the most
compact way to transmit this information
there are four possible patterns you
have two zeros
you could have 0 1 1 0 and 1 1
however I've got to be careful here
because what we've done and referring
back to what I've said previously about
compression methods what I've done here
is devised a code which has no
redundancy at all we've talked about how
to squeeze redundancy out of text files
and pictures which is what compression
is is getting rid of unnecessary
information
there's nothing unnecessary here every
one of those bits is vital and you
better hope they don't get lost or
distorted on the way
unfortunately they might get lost or
distorted on the way so the next thing
we have to say is these codes are
beautiful but they rely on you having
clean noiseless communication across
your telephone wire what would go wrong
if that wasn't the case just
occasionally one of these zero bits
that's signified by a short Boop for a
dot might get turned into a one because
part way to Sacramento suddenly an
electrical storm occurred and just so
what was received at Sacramento was not
the dude it was dude like that a longer
second bit and the people that saw
that's zero one it's sunny in San
Francisco no it isn't it's foggy so you
can see very quickly there is no
possibility for recovering from error in
these if you get an error people will
receive apparently a good pattern but it
will be for the wrong
weather condition how could you add
something extra to these to give them a
bit of protection against noisy
telephone line
simplest way one of the simplest has
been used in telecommunications and
indeed within computers for years and
years now you put in a parity check bit
so here's a code with a check bit and
all I'm gonna do here I will take every
two-bit code and turn it into a three
bit code but the rule will be that's in
the overall three bit code I must have
an even number of one bits so this is
called an even parity system so here we
go
zero zero there are no ones in that so
therefore at the right-hand end here and
they had in the parity check bit and
because we're on even parity it's a zero
viewers of numberphile will have to
forgive me I think there is a video on
there questioning whether zero is an
even number I'm sorry I'm just a
computer scientist people have a delayed
reaction people are not sure whether
zero isn't even that's even as far as
I'm concerned okay how about this one
zero one well overall it's got to be
even parity which means an even number
of ones
so my bit I had at the right hand end is
a one equally here for cloudy one and
zero
there it is two of them 101 rainy that's
easy as an even number of ones already
so I put a zero at the end now those
codes with the check bit they help a lot
in helping to detect whether an error
has occurred just suppose that when this
zero zero zero was sent it got distorted
again an electrical disturbance to chew
up one of the zero bits lengthen it and
make it look like zero one zero if any
of these got distorted an Auton to a 1
or a 1 turn to a zero he looks like a
valid different weather state here it
doesn't because the look at the valid
codes three zeros 0 1 1 1 0 1 1 1 0 I
sent this and it arrived at the
and as zero one zero is this a code
that's in this set no it isn't if you
try with these just changing any one of
the bits and flipping it either a 1 to a
0 or a 0 to a 1 you end up with
something that isn't in this list of
good valid codes you could say well
there's bad codes there's things that
don't correspond to any of these and of
course with 3 bits 2 to the power of 3
is 8 so there's 8 possible combinations
what we've done here is split them up
into four good codes that are meaningful
and four bad ones but the bad ones give
you a protection against errors in
transmission at your listening station
you hear 0 1 0 and you said I can't be
right what's the simplest thing to do to
try and find out what the weather really
is because you know the known errors
occurred well the simplest thing is to
send back to San Francisco a simple one
bit message either a naught or a 1 you
either say acknowledge in other words I
got it it's a good code or not
acknowledged here I would send back a
not acknowledge often called a knack for
not acknowledge a sent back a 1 bit
which says not acknowledged got garbage
and the sending end would say okay let's
keep it simple just send it again
no not naught next time you hope it's
going to get through without distortion
so this is the basis of this system in
that it can detect that a single error
has occurred the only trouble is that it
can't tell you where the error occurred
just consider the following I have got 0
1 0 here by changing the middle 0 into a
1 but it could have happened that he
came from this one via Distortion it
could have been that the bit that got
distorted was not that one or that one
but that one that the trailing one bit
might have got turned back into a zero
there's an error but I don't know
whether it came from this one or from
this one so this kind of code then can
detect one error
but it can't correct it it can't tell
you where it occurred suppose I had a
even noisier line and that in one of
these three bit codes you hope most of
them are gonna go through cleanly you
hope that the ones that aren't clean
will have a most one error in them what
happens if I send one zero one and there
are two errors in there not just one the
errors just so happen that it turns a
long blip into a short one there and
there that would then give you zero zero
zero two errors Oh
calamity again this is received at the
receiving station they say hey fantastic
zero zero zero it's foggy in San
Francisco no it isn't it's cloudy but it
got two errors so it looks like it was
foggy so the point here is it's
resilient against one error they can
detect it II can't correct it but
against two errors that isn't resilience
it just thoughts it into a good-looking
code again so for this reason this
system is called a distance two code
because what it's saying is if you flip
two bits
it changes into another good code if you
flip one bit it's discernibly garbage
and you can say and eros occurred it's
18 megabytes and let me say again 18
megabytes not 80 gigabytes and it's in
this huge package base combination of
art and science that goes into making
game is an extraordinary thing